I finished my second month testing for joe tippins. So this person joe tippins protocol is a
Fendezale protocol so they're on Fendezale and they're talking about testing because I'm asking
people if you're taking Fendezale and or Ivermectin that you run the comprehensive metabolic profile
at least. So the first month kidney markers on the comprehensive metabolic profile were off.
This month kidney numbers are back in line though the BUN and the BUN
CreatedD ratio is off more than the first month. So this person did give me the ranges.
Their ALT and AST was normal. That alkaline phosphatase the first month was 71 now it's back down to 44.
So 71 is even within lower range but now it's lowered yet. And their BUN was 23 now it's 21. Now understand
the understand the difference between lab ranges and functional ranges. So any lab could give you any
range that they are demidormal or abnormal. But for the functional medicine understanding the functional
ranges are much tighter. So the functional range is the functional high BUN is actually 15. So even your
21 is still outside of functional range. Now let me finish a question here because I think she addresses
that. Funny thing is the different I use different labs. I have a new year new insurance so different
reference ranges. Yes so different labs can use different reference ranges. My BUN would still be
considered high under the first lab range but is in range with this lab. I explained that. But really
functional lab range of BUN is really 0 to 15. That's really considered normal range or you could
say 0 or 10 to excuse me 10 to 15 but really 10 to 16. So 10 to 16 is the functional range of BUN.
So even at 21 you're still high. Creativity was within normal range. Following first labs we
pulsed fed vendors and fed vendors all two weeks on two weeks off. And I've been taking 222 milligrams
two times daily. Still did that on by on two weeks. What are your thoughts now? Keep pulsing fed
is all I ever back to it was 32 milligrams twice daily. Not pulsing that yet.
Personally I still think your BUN is too high. And it did it if it only came down
one point that's within you know abnormal readings or two points that's still that's not the
still kind of within abnormal range. Especially with used a different lab. I would I would consider
partly depends. So should I stop doing this protocol at risk of damaging my kidneys? Well you know
if my cancer the part of the decision making process if my cancer is growing like crazy you know
when I have to do something then you have to decide the risk and reward in this. And gosh by
BUN be 23 and down down to 21 is that really you know causing damage to my kidneys? Well I don't
know what is your normal maybe your normal was 11 before all this I don't know but it's it's
you know you just have to weigh out that risk and reward if you're if you're answered to that question
is well no my cancer wasn't going crazy. I thought it was fairly stable and I just wanted to try
this to see if I could really knock it down. Then I personally I would consider going off of it for a
month and see if I could bring those levels down a little bit and then try it. I don't know you're
going to make that decision you probably we could talk that over but that's kind of how you go through
that decision making process I think.